ん
[音楽]
ます
じゃあ
あの僕はあのよく人生相談を頼まれるんですけどあの
必ず言われるのが自分に自信がないっていうことなんですよ
あなたは自分自身でありますかデイ
この話あのしょっちゅう聞くんですもんでほとんど自己肯定感話ですね
もうね口を開けばもう時刻を転換がないっていうことをも割とまあ
世界的な病気になってますよね自分のことを自信がないみたいなエアーそうですか大変
ですねみたいな話を必ず付くんです言ってたんですけど途中で気がついたんですよ
あれちょっと待てよと
あの口ではそう言ってるけど本当はどうなのかツって
本当は自分だけは大丈夫だってどっかで思ってるんじゃないかって思ったんです
漫画家になりたいです見たいと集まってでも自信ないですって言うんだけど本当はこの
中で俺だけは成功すると思ってるんだ
この中で皆さん何かやるときに失敗するのは隣の奴だと
自分以外のやつか失敗するとそういうふうに思って何か大きな不幸が起こるのは自分
以外だっていうくらいに
どっかで思っている思ってない生きていけないです人間は
ねだからよく
あの恋愛相談とかであの出会いがないんですとか私もてないんですとか僕もてないです
一生あのひとりぼっちて死ぬんじゃないかと思ってるんですか言いながらもどこかで
自分だけはいいから必ずいい人と出会える
設定になってるんですよそれは全然間違ってないっていうことで
これよく考えたんですよなんだかんだ時刻古典からないとか言いながら
なんか最終的に何か[ __ ]はんじゃないかと思って
よく考えたらこういうことなんじゃないかと
誰の心の中にもちっちゃい神様がいいてだいたいこういうイメージなんですけど
ブーバですねぇこれちっちゃおかしくないですか
俺なら自信家
ないっていうのは最初は大きかった神様がどんどんどんな
いやいや無理だよお前なんか無理だと言われながらだんだんだんだんその現実を知り
なさいって言われてなんだこちっちゃくなったんじゃないかなと思うようになったわけ
ですよ
で
子供と切手 ok なことを語る方が受けるじゃないですか
あの昔はねよくあの宇宙飛行士になりますとか
ビルゲイツになりますとか何か言うと多い
いいねぇなっていうふうな小学と言われるわけですよそれがだんだんその a
高校生ぐらいで乳児者になりますというとみたいな感じですよね
売りが歪む二十歳越えてアイドルになりましたけどあぁそう
頑張ってねみたいな感じになってくるのはどういうことなんだ俺はおかしいじゃない
かっていう風にちょっと思うようになったわけですよ
で特にですね僕実は僕
漫画家なんですよ
で楽しく漫画書いているところですけど
あの漫画家って冷静に考えたら
あの普通夢を諦めないといけないそういう確率の職業なんですけど
でねどうしてかっちゅうとクラスの中にね僕の世代なく特に版がかなりた人多かったん
で
1人くらいはアホみたいに絵が上手い奴いるんですよ
絶対敵わないや1日いたじゃないですかクラスに一人ってことは学校に何にいるんだと
そして僕の年代だけでも同世代だけでも何人ライバルがいるとかざっと計算してみまし
た
あしますこれはっはー
これあのちなみに僕が子供の時ねあの海にね
旅行に行った時に民宿について海に行かずに漫画を書いているところです
それくらい僕が後から漫画書くのがで大好きで漫画家になるつもりでいたんですけど
あの絵が下手だったわけですよ普通ここであきらめるじゃないですか
哲麺
レシィさっきの話ここですいません4万人です
だからあの漫画で食える人ってああ
0.003%くらいしかいないというその漫画家になりたいと思った人の中の本と
わずかしか
つまり
絵が下手であのライバルがこんだけ居るって事は普通で大人は文優しく
他のこともいいんじゃないのを見てが知事になるわけですよ
ところがですね僕このその子供と時点で漫画家になるってその疑っにょん
ちびりの疑ってやばいですで絶対になるって自分の中で決まってたんですよ
で
そのままずーっときちゃったんですけど途中で気が付いたんですよ
これ俺はおかしいぞ
自分が見えてないで得しておかしいの価値はわかったんですけど実はこういうことです
呪いにかけられん
でこの呪いをかけた人が分かりました考えているございましたこの方です
おばあちゃんですね
を歯医者っていうの
で僕漫画家になるよって言ってる小学生の僕にみんな
無理ですよっていう風な感じだったんですよでも僕はなるんだって言ってた
ある時おばあちゃん読んで僕に言ったんですん
レジ
あのね聞きなさい
あなたは大丈夫
根拠もなくおばあちゃん言ったわけです僕砂をなんでだよねおばあちゃ
僕は大丈夫だなって思って僕にはできるよねって言ったら
できるよって言われたんですよこの呪いがー
強烈県政をつくったわけ種
よく言うじゃねえ体さえて何買って才能って何か僕は思い込みだと思うんですよ
思い込みって自分から内発的に出てくる思い込みと人からもらう
覚え込みがあってこの二つが合わさると小さな神様がムースとパープル
なるんですよねーこれがでまぁ思いっきり勘違いした版ま
僕はあの漫画家になるっていう決めてで
へ投稿するんですよ出版社に持ち込みもするんですよ
で10回
出しました10回落ちました普通止めるじゃないですか
でも違う神様がいいほっとかないですよいやいやいや絶対大丈夫だからそんな
11回目だから釣ってで11回目で出るするんですよ
これが二十歳の時ですであのなぜ犯達って言うかっていうと本当に一気急いでたわけ
ですよね早く出るしたい早くプロになりたいと思って大急ぎで探検漫画書いてたので
この時点でデビューする200サックぐらいも帰ってるんですけどね
ところがですねデビューんで意外と簡単だってことだとわかったんですよ
小もらうだけだから
だから島耕作が面白かったらレーベルにできちゃうんですよ
問題はその後なんですよ連載をとってヒットしないと次がないんです
それがまた延々と時刻が続くつこれヒット作でない地獄編の時の僕です
これが掛けても掛けても
売れないんですよで7回売れなかった77田口輝良れてと連載を普通の中でもやらせて
もらえませんよ
でも必死で売り込んで7回レーサーへ行ったんです7回嫌いだ
ツアー名じゃないですか違う僕はもう決まってますか
底材なんですたかっ
閉校すると基板てるっておばあちゃん言ったんだよっていうことで続けてたらあの
8回目でヒットがいるわけですよ
でこうなるとつまりその
漠然とあれちょっとおかしいんじゃないのって思っているのが確信に変わるわけですよ
ああやっぱりこれはおばあちゃん間違ってない
汚れを選ばれている
俺は大丈夫なんだっていうのがもう完全に立って普通飽きられるんだけどあきらめ
なかったらチェックでちゃうんですよ
結果でちゃったんでもうこうなると止められないですよ
もうあとはもうみんなを幸せにしなきゃいけないと思っちゃうんですよ
それで僕は地球を守るで消えましてこれあの日左のやつはあれですね
資本主義卒業試験って言って
世の中にはちょっと狂ってるとし方式で終わらせなきゃいけないって本出したりとか
右の奴は環境問題ですね温暖化の漫画とか入ってたりとかそこまで行くようになったん
ですよ
でところがですね
ある時考えたんですよやっぱり僕は映画下手なんです
で友達の満額はめちゃめちゃうまいんです
みんな絵が上手いですんであれちょっと待って奴って
でも呪われてるからだよなぁと思いながら俺だけかと思ったんですよ
俺だけが呪われてるのかちょっと探そうと思っ
でそれじゃあ対談漫画って始めます2003年に恋
やつです絶望に効くクスリってやつでこれはね実は2003年でバブルの崩壊後
ごまかし効かなくなってワールドカップとかでごまかしたんですけど本当にも毎日
100人自殺するっていう授業きちゃったんです
でそのときに
どうやったら幸せになれるのか幸せな人は何やってんのかって直接会いに行って確認
しようと思って
400人くらい後に入ってますチラ見こういう人たちもあってます
オリバーストーンとかね寂聴さんとか予定
色々あってはシャーリーズセロン誰ですねマッドマックスのフィリオさですね
2杯引退とかして水木先生とかっていう
これ以外にも色んな人に会いに行ったんですよみんな聞いたしてぼく何であなたは皆
成功して幸せそうなのかな
話したという印象をこういう感じです
みんなおかしい
[音楽]
アシーナある持ってみんな普通じゃないなぁと思ってどういうふうにおかしいかという
とこういうことです
自分は特別だって確信してるんですよクドカンコートくんとかもそうでしたよ
あのーなんか僕はうまくいっちゃうと思ったんですよねみたいなこいつも鈍いかかって
いる
お前もかお前もからみたいな感じですよそれで一人力を聞いてないんですよ
まあ聞いてると思いますよ聞いてない人が多いんですで中には
ねあのー座右の銘くださいというと人の言うことなんか聞くなって夕日とかすごい
で曲げにええまあその子のことの話なんて
ね呪いをかけたのは誰だっていう話聞くじゃないですか
もちろん年
親である晩は場合もあるんですよお父さんとかお母さんに言われてそういう自己肯定感
を使いましたって人もいるんですけどこれ実は親だけじゃないっていうことが
昔かですけどね
hey
親だけ舌でいろんなプレイヤーに入るわけで他にもね
おっとないわけじゃないですかで別に親じゃなくてもいいんだっていうことに気がつい
てそういえば俺もそうだ
おばあちゃんじゃっって思って呪いかけた人の範囲のはわかったっていうことですね
それでですね
呪いのコーナーで相場いっても山田さん
あのは僕は
あのあなたなように呪いをかけてくれた人がいないんですよ
で親もね成績が良くないと褒めてくれなかったと
で自己肯定感もらえなかったという人いると思うんですよねでそんなあなたもう大丈夫
だって言ってくる人もいなかったっていうと思うんですよ人たちのために今日は特別に
僕がの
呪いはかけますいいですか
かけちゃいますよでの会じゃあその前に鈍いかかるとどうなるかっていうのは効果効能
ができます
人の目が気にならなくなります
こんな感じの仕上がりなりませんえっ
これねみんな言ってますけどね1の人の言うことなんかホント大したことないですよ
ろくなことはないですから
人の目を気にするっていうかどんだけ意味がないかっていうことはもうみたい
実証済みなんですよなのに人の目が気になっちゃうよ
でもそれどーでもいーす本当はでそして失敗が怖くなくなる
この失敗の話ですけど
新しいことで初めて最初から成功することがまずないですよ
バッターボックスだって最初の一振りで homeland わけないじゃないですか
だからその後割バッターだって半分は打てないですよ
5割と使う必要
だから基本的に何かを始めたら失敗するんですよ
で失敗するってことは挑戦したっていう証拠なんですよ
つまり失敗したからもう学んで次行ってるわけでしょ
この失敗が怖くなくなるって言うわね強いんですよ
なにしろ10回落選しても平気ですからね
11回メリー何かが起こることがあるのでそれであともうひとですね
こんな男の話を聞いていいのだろう信じていいのかって思うじゃないですかね
思いますよそれは初めて会ったマーケット負ければた年頃にかけられてたまるかって
思ってるかもしれないしか
あれ心のファイアーウォールがね
でですが
あのーアナル信じない信じてねーよって言って良いです誰ですみんなみんなの前では
ところがみんなには内緒で信じている
信じちゃへは行っていいです
数別あ
それではいきますよをすべきかな時間営
ちょっとだけ目を閉じてください今から呪いかけますよ
あなたにはできます
いう cad 位
上を開けてください
僕一つだけ気付いたんですさっきから鈍い鈍いて言ってますけど
これ実は祝福だったと
これは呪いじゃなくておばあちゃんが
このように生まれてくれた僕に祝福としてあなたは大丈夫って言ってくれたってことが
後なんと分かったってことはね
あったので今日は鈍いって言ってますけど
皆さんを祝福しに来ました
地球にようこそ
君はもう大丈夫
ありがとうございましたよ奴隷でしたーー
[拍手]